What if it was more like this?
We don't notice the Earth's spinning now,
so what would life be like if it's spun a little faster?
Would we all just get really,
really dizzy?
How would we cope with shorter days and less sleep?
How would it affect our climate or geography?
If this is modern life,
can we survive any faster?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if the earth spun twice as fast.
We don't feel the earth spinning because along with everything else on this
planet,
we're spinning right along with it.
At the equator,
if the world turns out roughly 1600 kilometers per hour,
completing a full rotation in 24 hours,
so if you stood on the equator,
you would travel about 40,000 kilometers in one day,
spending twice as fast,
you'd lose half your day.
Time would fly,
but you wouldn't be having any fun.
Let's start with the good news.
Weight loss.
That's right.
If the world's spun twice as fast,
you'd weigh a lot less all day.
Everyday.
Centrifical force from the Earth's rotation threatens to shake you off the
planet.
Luckily gravity is stronger and keeps you grounded.
Still at the equator you weigh about a half kilogram less because more
centrifical force is generated where the earth is spinning faster,
which ever so slightly decreases.
Gravity's hold on you so double the speed of earth spin and we're all the
biggest loser.
That is because things are about to get a lot worse.
I think of all your favorite TV shows and try to come to terms with the fact
that you'll never catch the next episode.
Most of our satellites that are used for communications,
military intelligence and television broadcasting are synchronized with the
earth's rotation.
Even the smallest increase of speed would cause them to spin out of orbit,
but who's even got time for TV these days when days are only half as long?
Do you think he could function on four hours of sleep instead of eight?
How about one or two meals a day instead of three?
Humans would have to design new schedules and new calendars because instead of
365 days in a year,
there would now be 730 hopefully there'd be twice as many holidays as well.
Adjusting to a new biological clock would be tough and not everyone would make
it.
For example,
nocturnal species would have fewer hunting hours and may face extinction if they
couldn't adapt,
but humans would need to become more efficient too,
especially in terms of energy.
For the average person who drives to work,
they would now have to commute twice as often doubling fuel consumption and its
effect on our climate.
But really the climate would be beyond saving for starters,
extreme,
whether it would be much more well extreme due to the curvature of the earth,
wind and water curve too,
as they travel across her the surface,
this is the Coriolis effect and it's the phenomenon that gives hurricanes there
spin.
So the faster the rotation of the earth,
the more the winds curve,
the more hurricanes spin,
and the more energy they carry with them.
Put simply deadlier disasters.
But if you'd like to think of yourself as a storm Chaser,
well then hopefully you're a strong swimmer too.
With the Earth spinning at 3,200 kilometers per hour,
the centrifical force would essentially pull all the water from the northern and
southern hemispheres towards the equator.
Countries like Ecuador,
Columbia,
Venezuela,
Brazil,
Kenya,
Indonesia,
Singapore,
and Australia would be partially,
if not completely submerged on top of this,
reduced gravity and the Ecuadorian region would produce more moisture of ring of
dense fog and constant rain would permanently cover the earth's waistline.
So the next time you have a long day,
be glad it wasn't shorter.
Our way of life depends on it live in the moment,
24 hours a day,
365 days a year.